n agissons fortement et résolument en
direction des femmes et des plus
jeunes merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur le ministre les instructions de
la direction général de l'alimentation
relative à l'obtention d'un certificat
phytosanitaire pour l'export de grumes
non écorcé sont
[Musique]
irréalisable la seule possibilité que
vous laissez aux professionnel de la
filière bois et l'csage or d'une part
les clients chinois représentant 80 %
des exportations françaises refuse de
recevoir des bois écorcés et d'autre
part le nombre d'écorseuse adapté à la
conformation des grumes de qualité
secondaire est aujourd'hui
insuffisant l'application de ces
instructions depuis le 1er juillet va
entraîner l'arrêt des achats de bois sur
pied des coupes de bois de qualité
secondaire la cessation d'activité de
plus de 1000 entreprises du bois une
aggravation de 2 milliards
supplémentaires du déficit de la filière
monsieur le ministre soucieux de trouver
des solutions durables les
professionnels forestiers concernés ont
développé deux alternatives en attente
d'autorisation un traitement par
brumisation de forestè en containur et
en zone dédié un traitement thermique à
56 degr sous écorces en conformité avec
les normes internationales et qui doit
être validé par la Chine aussi Monsieur
le Ministre ma question est simple
allez-vous autoriser à titre dérogatoire
et je dis bien à titre dérogatoire
l'utilisation du forestère par
pulvérisation le temps de finaliser les
solutions alternatives merci la parole
est à Monsieur Stéphane Lefol ministre
de l'Agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et
de la
forêturés député vous AZ équé le sujet
des traitements phytosanitaires pour les
bois exportés d'abord je voudrais qu'on
soit bien clair l'objectif d'un grand
pays comme la France n'est pas
uniquement d'exporter des bois qui sont
ensuite transformés dans d'autres pays
du monde que ça soit en Chine que ça
soit ailleurs dans les pays du monde
c'est aussi de transformer nos propres
bois ça c'est le premier point et ne
l'oubliez pas en particulier quand on
vient de département où il y a des
sirriies de première transformation qui
me demandent justement de durcir les
conditions d'exportation des bois donc
sur ce débat chaque maillon de la
filière compte sur la question que vous
avez posé oui j'avais décidé et dit
qu'au 1er juillet s'appliqueraiit les
nouvelles règles puis par que on ne peut
plus pulvériser des phytosanitaires d'
cpémétrine sur les bordures de forêt et
3 mois ont été donnés supplémentaires
pour assurer deux possibilités de
traiter ces bois l'écorchage vous l'avez
dit et les procédures thermiques qui
sont en place dans un certain nombre de
ports de France en particulier pour
faire en sorte que sur ces procédures et
bien les exportateurs de bois a trouvé
les solution ont les solutions au moment
où il souhaitent exporter mais on ne
peut plus autoriser les pulvérisations
de phytosanitaires dans les forêts ça
c'est clair et je n'y reviendrai pas on
a eu 3 mois de surci ça s'applique au
1er juillet et ça s'appliquera mais sur
les questions que vous avez posé sur les
corçage sur la Chine très bien mais sur
les la procédure thermique elle existe
elle est mise en place il y a maintenant
dans les ports de France des capacité de
en tout cas des capacités à traiter les
bois de manière thermique pour qu'il
puisse être ensuite exporter c'est en
tout cas les règles qui s'appliquent
maintenant